nothing says galentine's day like a
night out with the girls but as we all
know that's not happening
so when a viewer named
ayanna reached out for advice on
planning something special for her and
her friends
i had an idea but first take a look
hi drew me and my girls
love galentines in the past we've done
bowling
wine tasting and be a vision board party
or two but this year
is a lot different because of the
pandemic shamika and donisha
are two of my best friends and we want
to do galentines
this year my girls are also very
inspiring
and they really have my back we do
volunteer work with each other and
support each other
as women entrepreneurs and girl bosses i
need your help drew you want to have a
little fun
and i'm wondering if you have any fun
galentine's day
ideas well i do
welcome shamika donisha and ayanna
[Music]
hi drew i'm so excited to hang out with
you guys
i really feel like we've got some we've
got a good idea cooking here now how
long have you guys been friends
so we've been friends for over 10
years these ladies have been there for
me they always have my back
and wow i could always count on them
always
i love that and denisha
um what do you love about galentine's
day
drew i love the fact that these ladies
are my trolleys angels my
tribe and i get to celebrate them today
and this is
fantastic thank you so much oh
there is something very powerful about a
trio of ladies i'm not sure what it is
but it works i'm so glad to hear that
okay ayanna have you ever done
an art class together well you know
we've done some art classes like vision
board parties and things like that
and shamika has like a bit of a more
formal art training
so listen we put together a little art
class
and it has a twist i'm to show you the
subject you'll be drawing
meet gabriel
hey um
gabriel you're a yale graduate right
i am yeah don't be don't be fooled here
with his boxers and his gorgeous
positioning
now floor childs will be your instructor
today hi
fleur hello thanks for inviting us on
the show today we're so excited
well um tell us the name of your company
please
sure um the company is called the artful
bachelorette
and uh we've been helping people find
their inner artist
for eight years now while appreciating
the human form
i love it okay so what are our girls
gonna be doing today
right you've met beautiful gabrielle um
he is one of our most popular
male muses and he's going to inspire you
for our galentine's day special
do you think you girls will be okay
drawing game for the next hour
yes yes
all right girls are you ready yes
ready set draw yeah
we're gonna see you throughout the show
and check in on how you're doing
let's check in with our galentine's day
artistes
ladies shamika danisha ayanna how's it
going
it's going great i'm loving this
you got anything to show us so far are
we waiting for a big reveal
definitely a big reveal and we are
our headmaster hello and gabriel
comfortable
love it all right we're gonna check back
in with you guys a little later
earlier in the show we invite a group of
girlfriends to take part in a drawing
class
to celebrate valentine's day and our
girlfriends have been busy with their
art creations
but it's time for them to drop their
pens and reveal their finished products
all right shamika danisha ayana are you
ready
yes one two
three reveal the big reveal
[Applause]
okay oh my gosh
that's wow i'm really impressed
but you know what don't take my word for
it fleur
um the mistress of uh the art class
what do you think of everyone's work i
mean this has been such a treat
shamika is a real talent um
like she's really got some wonderful
skills there i'd love to
you know see all of her artworks and
then
we have ayanna who i think uh
is definitely a personal favorite with
her swipe right
humor on the bottom of her
straight lines only and so they had to
put
gabrielle who is you know an organic
form
into a whole bunch of straight lines
which was super fun
and then denisha is just super cute
there and i love
all of her lines and her cheeky smile
well i mean that's really impressive
actually because here's my drawing i
decided to just go along
with you guys wow and um this should
make you feel good about all your
paintings
um okay you guys are all winners and
we want to make sure that you get to
celebrate together as soon as it is safe
so
we want to give you the ultimate
galentine's getaway
in palm springs california
[Applause]
yeah you're gonna enjoy a six night
seven day stay
in the presidential suite
[Music]
at the westin mission hills golf resort
and spa
presidential suite overlooking the
stunning mountain views in the southern
california desert oasis
you're going to enjoy local cuisine and
spa treatments courtesy of visit
greater palm springs and the three of
you will fly courtesy
of jet blue and gabriel we have a
special
robe just for you look at the drew
barrymore look
that's for you to stay warm
thank you gabriel the yale graduate and
good dads club um thank you
uh may you adorn that robe in your cozy
cozies when you need it thank you
shamika danisha and ayanna
thank you floor and gabriel happy
galentine's day you guys this was so
much fun
you